So, this is how we're going to be able to
measure the power of a hypothesis space. This is a really
clever definition. I did not come up with this and it
goes like this. For a given input and hypothesis space, we're
going to ask what is the largest set of inputs
that the hypothesis class can label in all possible ways? So,
in this example that we were looking at, it's actually really
simple because it turns out the answer is one. so, here,
here's an example. So being able to do this with one is not such a
big deal. If S is a set of points, a set of inputs, in this case
just six, it's one of the inputs from the set. Then are there hypotheses in the
hypothesis class that can label this in all
possible ways? Well, there's only two possible ways.
It can label it as true and it can label
it as false. So, here if we set theta to
I don't know, five, it'll label it as true. If
we have a different hypothesis that say sets theta to
eight, then we can label it as false. There is
a set of inputs of size one that we can
label in all possible ways. But is there any pair
of inputs that we can label in all four ways?
>> I'm going to say no.
>> And why is that?
>> Well because you're writing it, you're writing it
in sets but I sort of think of these as
points on a number line, and theta as a separating line.
And there's just kind of no way to label
anything to the left of the line as negative, ever.
Because you're requiring that x is greater than equal to
theta to be positive, so you can never label anything
to the left of that line as negative. So all
I have to do, right, is make x1 negative and
x2 positive, and there's nothing you can do. Is that right?
>> Indeed it is. So, in particular, pick
any two points x1, x2 on the line just
like you said, if as we roll theta, if we just kind of consider sets of theta
as moving from left to right, it starts off where x1 and x2 are both going to
be labeled as true. Then as we move theta
to the right, x1 is going to eventually start
to be labeled false, so that okay, that's now two of
the combinations we've seen. We're going to keep moving theta to
the right, and now x2 is labeled as false. So we've
seen three of the combinations, but which combination didn't we see?
>> true, false.
>> And there's just no way to make that happen. Just like you said.
>> So would you say this is a weak hypothesis space?
>> It definitely seems to be pretty weak, even though
it's infinite. In fact, did it depend on x being finite?
>> No, actually, it
didn't. You're right.
>> Yeah, so all, so this really applies in the, in this very
general setting. We can take this definition, bring it to bear on an input
hypothesis pair like this, and it gives us a sense of how expressive
or how powerful the hypothesis space is. And in this case, not very expressive.